JENNA TAYLOR: Welcome
to The Teaching Kitchen
at Kitchen Sync.
I'm Jenna Taylor.
I'm a Food Services Manager
here on your Google Food
team in Mountain View.
Very excited to be
your hostess today.
So today we're very lucky to
have Chef Nathan Lyon with us.
Chef Lyon is the Emmy-nominated
chef and co-host of "Growing A
Greener World" and host of "Good
Food America" with Nathan Lyon.
You also might recognize him, as
I did from, Food Network Star.
NATHAN LYON: Yeah.
It's a long time ago.
I had hair down to here.
JENNA TAYLOR: It's a long
time ago, but I recall it.
You're also, what, a
sustainable seafood ambassador
with the aquarium, and
author of "Great Food Starts
Fresh," which a lot of us
are paging through right now.
So I'm going to leave it at
that and step out of the shot.
But welcome, and thank you
for being here with us today.
NATHAN LYON: Thanks, guys.
Exciting.
So thank you, Jenna.
Huge round of applause
for this young lady,
Victoria, because I
wouldn't be here otherwise.
My girlfriend and executive sous
chef is out there with Chef--
her name is Sarah Forman.
And also, when you go
to in the cookbook,
numerous places it'll say,
for additional information
go to chefnathanlyon.com I have
a bunch of cards right here,
takes you to the same place.
Sarah and I started doing
drought-friendly recipes, also,
that get picked up by NPR.
The French version of CNN
came to our humble abode
and kind of watched us cook.
Our voices will be
dubbed in French,
so I can't wait to
actually see it.
I'll be like, what's my
French voice going to be?
I hope it's not squeaky
and really high.
Who knows?
I don't know.
And you can find
those online also.
So because you all
have cookbooks,
this book took me
six years to finish.
The reason why is
I'm a perfectionist,
and I just keep going
back and I think I
can do it a little bit better.
But it's based on my 10 years
of working at farmer's markets.
And the thing about
working at farmers' markets
is you develop this amazing
Rolodex of information
that makes it so that your
life is a lot simpler.
Going to culinary
school and teaching
people how to cook
on TV also make sure
your life a lot simpler.
So for example,
when you know how
to pick out a tomato,
or you how to pick out
a peach without smelling it or
touching it-- because that's
what I used to sell
for 10 years-- that
makes your job a
lot easier, so you
use a lot less mental energy.
Like, if you're
typing something,
return key is always here.
You don't have to go, hm-hm,
oh, there it is, return, right?
So I'm going to show you
a couple knife skills that
will be, like, a habit.
It'll be a new habit.
So you don't have to worry
about cutting certain things
because as you're
cutting them, you're
thinking about something else.
So we're sort of multitasking.
I am the youngest of three boys.
I'm from Arlington, Virginia.
I love attention.
I had no idea that I
would be a teacher.
I love to teach, and
this is what I do.
I was an art major,
meaning before I switched
to a health science major.
I was a medical technician.
I did landscaping.
I'm a chef.
So I'm kind of all
over the place.
But this is what
I love the most,
and it's sort of like everything
I've ever done in my whole life
has come to fruition here.
So does anyone not
have a blender at home?
You don't have a blender.
OK, so whoever she lies--
whoever lives next to her,
we need to make sure that
she comes to your house
to make this first recipe.
If your birthday is coming
up, and then we can all
pitch in five bucks, right?
And we can get you
an immersion wand.
Those are really
great things to have.
So if you don't
have a blender, you
can get an immersion and, which
is like a-- it's like this,
but it's got the blender
thing on this end--
bzzz- that whole thing, right?
So you can make this first
recipe with one of those.
Whatever sound effects--
bzzz-- that's mine.
You can come up with
your own sound effect.
But this is a spicy
watermelon gazpacho.
This first recipe is an
homage to all the things
that summer has to offer.
So when I was in
school, I realized
that when you eat in
season, it's better for you
physiologically.
So these types of fruits--
these are all fruits-- these
are all very
cooling to the body.
So if it's 100 degrees
outside, and I said,
so today I'm making a
roast Tahitian squash
risotto with, like,
cream and butter,
and you're like, blaahhh, right?
Because it's just so hot
you don't want those things.
Luckily for us,
they're not in season.
So everything you should be
eating is in front of you
when you should be eating it.
It has the most flavor,
it costs the least,
and has the most nutrition.
And that's why I
did this cookbook.
So first things first.
Does anyone not like watermelon?
I love watermelon.
I'm, again, from Virginia.
We used to go out--
my buddy Jason Hicks
and I used to go to
the watermelon fields,
and actually go out and
it was $0.25 a watermelon.
So we used to go out there
with a knife and a spoon,
and just be like, eat the heart,
$0.25, eat the heart, $0.25.
Isn't that cool?
Well, we were stuffed
and peeing ourselves,
but at the end of the day,
it was absolutely delicious.
So this first recipe, because
it is so warm outside,
I thought I'd do this one first
because it is very cooling.
I know the chef has made
it absolutely delicious.
And you can make
it ahead of time,
and then put the entire blender
in the fridge to cool down.
And then when your
guests come over
on a hot summer day like
this, you just pour it out.
And they're just so stoked.
And if it's a weekend, you
through in vodka if you want.
They'd be like crazy stoked.
Just grab yourself a Google
bicycle and bike one home.
[BRIEFLY HUMS WICKED WITCH THEME
FROM "THE WIZARD OF OZ"]
So don't go crazy.
Thank you for picking that up.
That was very sweet
of you to do that.
So here's the watermelon.
You guys are so funny.
And what I said before,
everyone came in,
don't hesitate to
ask any questions.
Picking out a watermelon.
Does anyone know how to
pick out a watermelon?
That's a great question.
Great question, Nathan.
That's a fantastic question.
You thump on it.
You'll thump on it,
and it needs to sound
very resonant and hollow,
like a deep hollow.
If it's tinny, like ding,
ding, ding, it's underripe.
If it's like, phoomp, like
a wet shoebox, overripe.
And plus it's just fantastic.
Do you have one of these?
Vegetable peeler?
Doesn't have to be this one.
It could be this one.
I'm so going to tease you.
I'm so sorry.
I just feel bad that the
tier, the second tier.
When the third tier happens,
it's just something bad.
So if you don't
have one of these,
you'll have like the
old metal grandma style
one, which I have at home.
Is this a left- or
right-handed peeler?
Great question.
Peelers are all
for ambidextrous.
It doesn't matter if
it's left and right.
So if you're a right-handed
person like I am and you're
always peeling away,
that means that side's
duller than the part
coming towards you.
Does that makes sense?
So if I have a peeler-- and
when you're in restaurant work
and you figure out how to
peel like this-- like this
is a carrot, right,
so that's done.
So you don't always
have to be, like,
one, and then turn,
and two, then turn,
because both sides
peel exactly the same.
So the reason I'm
sharing that with you
is because when you have
friends coming over,
and you're like, oh my god,
I have to make a salad,
or whatever going to be
making, in 15 minutes,
there are numerous
items in that cookbook
that you could bang
out in 15, 20 minutes.
And that's just one of
those time-saving things
that you can use the
peeler both ways.
And I guarantee, as I'm
gesturing with this thing,
that when you go home
and use your peeler,
you'll be like, I'll be
darned, and just peel
both ways, away and toward you.
It's just a sharp, if not
sharper, on the opposite side.
Now if you have a Japanese
cucumber or a Persian cucumber,
you don't necessarily
have to peel it.
But for this one, because
you eat with your eyes first,
I want to make sure it's red,
if not kind of rosy pink.
And the green peel will sort
of make it a little bit more
on the brown side.
That's the only reason
why I'm peeling this.
Otherwise I would totally just
eat this peeled, everything.
Any questions, guys?
And again, this first one,
I'm just making it simple,
if you have a
blender--except for you--
you just throw
everything in a blender.
And that's really
the first recipe.
These are a little
bit on the small side,
meaning which is what I like.
If you get the big,
massive, tube sock,
hothouse massive ones, they
don't have a lot of flavor,
and plus they're very watery.
If you get those and
you have those at home,
you can cut them in
half and use the back
of a-- like this little spoon,
you scoop out the seeds.
It's just really watery.
There's not a lot of
flavor in that area.
I mean, if I wanted to, I could
totally pull you up and say,
make us all gazpacho,
and you would totally
be able to do this.
Any questions about anything?
Now let's do an
onion, a red onion.
Now the thing about onions
and cutting, and just the way
that you approach food itself,
because my background is
sort of like
physiology, cadaver lab,
that whole thing in college,
I always watch people cook.
And sometimes it looks
uncomfortable when people cook.
So if you're one of those people
that after you're done cooking,
you're like, geez, man,
that took it out of me--
chances are the way you cook
has something to do with that.
I have to make it so
you can all see here.
There's nothing up the sleeve.
So with an onion,
what I like to do
is because it's in the
blender, you can quarter it.
But I'm just going to
chop this pretty fine
so you can see how I'm going
to be approaching this.
If I'm relaxed--
if I'm relaxed--
this is relaxed to me.
Do I look relaxed?
So my hands are actually
not facing forward.
They're facing in a little bit.
And I could all I ask
you to stand up and do
the same thing, which is silly.
We'll just pretend that
we're all human beings.
So if I put this knife
in my relaxed hand,
it's actually facing
inward, not this way.
So if I want to cut
something straight,
I'm not going to do this.
I'm actually going to do this.
I'm just going to do this.
You can all do this, right?
So if I want to cut
something straight,
I'm going to turn this
onion to the same angle
as the knife would normally be
if I'm just totally relaxed.
And people always do this
because this is perpendicular
and you know that's
straight, so you're like,
this is going to be
totally straight.
And you're just like,
what are you doing?
It's like Cirque
du Soleil cooking.
So if this was straight,
I would just do that,
and it's completely straight.
And I could literally
do this all day.
Where you looking?
And it's just-- I know it's
straight, just because all I
have to do this, up and down,
up and down, that's all,
and let the knife do the work.
So I'll throw some
red onion in there.
Next thing is tomato
with the gazpacho.
Now tomatoes-- you don't ever
want to refrigerate a tomato.
You just don't.
They cry and scream
a silent scream.
You won't be able to sleep.
It's horrible.
Because it messes up the inside.
The integrity gets
a little bit mealy.
So you can put them
on the counter,
not in the direct sunlight.
But when they're ripe,
that's good to go.
Or, if you go to your farmer's
market and there's a lot
of tomatoes, you're like, oh,
$1.00 a pound for heirlooms,
that's great.
You can just grab a whole
flat--it's totally worth it--
get freezer zip bags, put
them all in a freezer zip bag,
and just put them
in the freezer.
The reason for that is
because when you can a tomato,
you're kind of boiling it.
You're heating it,
so you're canning it.
So you're actually breaking
down the flavor of that tomato
by heating it for a
long period of time.
When you freeze it, it doesn't
break down the flavor at all.
And then, come winter time,
when you want to make yourself
like a really delicious grilled
cheese sandwich with tomato
soup, you just put it
under cold running water,
and then the frost just
on the inside of the skin
peels off like a sock.
And you just throw the
whole thing in your pot.
It has a lot of flavor
in there, so you don't
have to actually do anything.
You can neglect your produce
and have amazing food.
That sounds pretty good.
I don't know if
that's the Google way,
but let me tell you, that
could be the lion way.
So that goes in.
Does anybody have a knife that
they really like that they use?
Anybody have a knife they like?
You're like, well, kind of.
That's like saying, do
you have a cat you like?
You're like, kind of.
I guess I kind of have
a cat that I like.
So a knife is the
most important thing.
It's just the most important
thing that you have.
Not more than loved ones, but
it's the most important thing
you have in your kitchen.
Keep it really sharp.
I have a $250 knife that I never
use because the handle's too
small for my hand.
So I kind of try
to overcompensate
because the handle's too small.
This handle fits my hand.
What size shoe do you have?
It's totally personal, but
what size shoe do you have?
Five.
I have a 12.
So you're like, Nathan,
those are some killer Aasics.
I wants size 12 Aasics.
Not that great.
So if our hands are
the different sizes,
you need to go try on knives
like you try on shoes,
or clothes, or whatever.
Just because it's
shiny and looks amazing
doesn't mean it's
a better knife.
This knife you can get on
Amazon, delivered for like $38.
There's a photo of this
very knife in the cookbook.
So if you ever forget what the
knife is, look in the cookbook.
You all have one.
You guys are just sponges.
I love you.
OK.
So onion.
We have tomatoes.
We have watermelon, mint.
Mint is one of those things
that's absolutely fabulous.
If you like to garden but
only have a little pot,
mint is one of those things
that's actually better
to do in a pot, or
else it just takes off.
It's crazy.
It's like bamboo.
You can't stop it.
And fresh mint, or fresh
herbs, any fresh herbs
are so much better.
It's just like, fresh herbs
are like the really talented
backup singers to a not very
talented but very attractive
front singer, you know?
You're like, oh, she's
great, but the backup singers
make it amazing.
That's what fresh
herbs are for me.
And cilantro.
Does anyone not like cilantro?
Is anyone one of those people?
OK, well, that's what I thought.
Not liking-- because it
tastes very soapy to people.
They just don't
like that flavor.
Fresh lemon.
Always have fresh
lemons on hand, OK?
And I'm a big person that
likes to use my hands.
So I don't like to have to
get out the little strainer,
and then do that, and
then wash the strainer.
Just wash your hands
like an adult person,
and it'll be totally fine.
I'll see a lot of
chefs put on gloves.
And then I'm just dying
to go to their house
and see if they put on gloves
when they cook themselves
dinner.
And if they don't, then
you're totally fine.
You don't have to put on gloves.
Just wash your hands.
Red bell pepper, or
orange, or yellow.
Not green.
There's a reason why you can get
five green bell peppers for $1,
and you can get one
red bell pepper for $1.
It tastes a lot better.
It's just a sweeter product.
Also, from a sort of
medical standpoint,
sometimes green bell peppers
can have a little lower GI tract
issues with people, all right?
So as a chef, I want the
most flavor possible.
So I'm on a quest for flavor.
And I know the red
has a lot of flavor.
That goes in.
And then the gentleman
had a question
about extra virgin olive oil.
And they do vary.
They vary greatly.
This is the olive
oil that I like.
There is a photo of this
olive oil in my cookbook, OK?
I've tried a lot of olive oils.
And what my girlfriend
and I have historically
done-- actually,
only once, I think--
is go to a grocery store
and say, that costs $15.
I'm not going to buy
it unless I taste it.
That's why farmers
markets are so great.
So really, all of us
could get on a Google
bus-- I know they exist now--
and we can go to the store,
and say all of us want to
try that one olive oil.
None of us are going to
buy it without trying it.
And we can totally do that.
And you can do that, and they'll
be like, that's a good idea.
I've never tried that either.
So olive oil.
I like extra virgin
olive oil because I
like the flavor of it.
But you also need to taste a lot
of different extra virgin olive
oils.
So you can make an olive oil out
of any olive, and some of them
are not very palatable.
I like this one because it has
a green but fruity taste to it
at the same time.
And we can actually pass
this around and have you
guys take shots, hold
you by your ankles
or whatever you want to do.
I don't even know
what works over here.
But an olive oil is one
of those things that will
take care of lots of issues.
So if something is too spicy,
the olive oil, the fat,
will actually coat your
palate and make it less spicy.
It'll make it more thick.
If it's too thin, you can
emulsify it, like this will be,
and it thickens
up really nicely.
And plus it just tastes amazing.
Salt and pepper.
Pepper, freshly ground.
Does anyone like coffee?
Coffee?
OK.
Has anyone ever made coffee
with 10-year-old coffee grounds?
It's disgusting.
Even the thought makes
me want to puke, sort of.
So fresh spice is
the same thing.
So if you get the grocery store
fresh spices-- tomatoes takes
a lot of salt-- if you get the
grocery store fresh spices that
are already ground,
they could be years old,
just like if you got
pre-ground coffee.
It could be-- you don't know
how old it is, necessarily,
so you always get the whole
bean, freshly roasted, grind
it yourself.
Same thing with black
pepper, any sort of spices.
It's totally, totally worth it.
And the salt that I
use in here is just
regular kosher salt. $2.19
for the however many pounds
or whatever it is.
And that's it.
Unless you talk incessantly by
yourself in your own kitchen,
you can certainly make
this faster than what
I'm making it here, OK?
But that's just me.
I talk a lot by myself.
We'll start out low just to
kind of see what happens.
I feel like I'm on an
infomercial right now.
And then you just keep
pressing it, and whatever,
and then you--
Sheila, I need help.
And then you just--
we have one of these.
But I like the immersion
little wand guy.
But this bad boy,
if you have one
of these, the you can
make it super silky,
like really smooth.
It's happening!
Maybe.
We'll see.
That's it.
So I would normally
put this in the fridge,
let it chill out for a bit.
Taste it.
Tasting is also very important.
If it needs more salt,
decide whether or not
you want to add a bit more acid.
So acid will bring out the
natural sodium in food.
So if you have anybody in
the family, or yourself,
you're watching how much sodium
you intake, the last little bit
you're like, hmm, does
it need more brightness,
or does it need more salt?
If it needs salt, salt it.
If it needs brightness, you
can add a little more red wine
vinegar or lemon juice,
and that will actually
bring up a little more sodium.
So hey, that's pretty good.
It's not that bad.
This recipe actually works.
Isn't that cool?
A little more black
pepper and a touch
of salt. Don't be
afraid of salt.
Just do not be afraid
of salt. It makes it
so that you can
actually taste things.
I mean, it's just
one of these things
that if something's missing,
you're like, what's missing?
Chances are it's the
salt. And what I want you
to do--it's
mesmerizing isn't it?
What I want you to get
in the habit of doing
is when you're making soups,
say this gazpacho or something,
and you're not
quite sure what it
is that's missing,
what I want you to do
is take a little spoon
like I did earlier,
take the little spoon, and just
put a little bit of gazpacho
on it, and then add just
like a couple dots of salt.
Once you add the salt to this
giant thing, you're done.
Maybe it needed acid.
So my girlfriend Sarah and
I have a little tiny bowls
on the side, so we're
constantly feeding it
from this big amount
to a little bowl.
And then will be like, oh, it
was the blank that we needed,
and then we'll add that,
finish the whole dish.
So that's it.
Even these Google
plates are beautiful.
If you put it in the
fridge, any sort of bubbles
will settle out.
But this seems to be good to go.
And then to let
people know what's
in it, just a little
bit of cilantro
that you won't have to
share with Mike or Victoria
because they don't like it.
A little bit of black pepper.
And then this little flair
is what gets everybody.
This is what you can
charge the extra $1.10
at your restaurants, is just
that little bit right there.
So there you are.
So you can feed lots
and lots of people
with a watermelon and a
couple vegetables that
are in season and super
full of flavor already.
So that is the first
recipe, everybody.
So there you have it.
Have at it.
Thanks, Chef.
You got it?
You guys are so quiet.
Oh, yes.
Where can you buy
a-- no, I'm kidding.
Yes, question.
AUDIENCE: Can I
have your blender?
No, just kidding.
NATHAN LYON: Well, do you have
one of the little swipey things
you can get in places?
Because I don't.
The question, I think, is
can I have your blunder.
Is that right?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, but
the real question
is, I like to get
balsamic vinegar,
but it always seems
to go more sour.
I don't know if
that's my imagination,
or maybe I got
the wrong vinegar.
How do I keep it
staying fresh and tasty?
NATHAN LYON: Balsamic vinegar
is one of those things
that they're already aged.
So if it's a good
balsamic-- I actually
like all the Lucchini products.
I don't get paid by them,
I'm not pimping them,
but I just happen to like it.
I've tasted a lot of
stuff that I like.
I like the red wine, white
wine, and their balsamic,
because it's aged, and then
it's aged in oak barrels.
So age actually gives it more
character, which is lovely.
If you're spending-- not here,
because I didn't spend anything
on the cappuccino I
just got-- but if you're
outside of Google land, right?
And you have to pay for
your coffee, and it's $3.50,
but you're only spending
$2.16 on a bottle this big
of balsamic vinegar,
that tells you something.
Everything that that balsamic
touches should make it vibrant
and beautiful and delicious.
It shouldn't make
your face implode
and be like, whoah, that
is just crazy off balance.
It should be balanced.
So is that balsamic
worth the money?
I mean, I think the Lucchini
balsamic is like 15 bucks,
but it's going to last you
months and months and months.
Whereas I don't know what
$15 is for cappuccinos,
but it's like, what, four
mornings of cappuccinos?
So you sort of have to
say, it was two years aged,
and it came from Modena, Italy
all the way across to New York,
all the way across
to California,
and I'm only paying $15 for it.
And it will make
everything blossom
into something delicious.
So I guess that's sort of, in
a very long way, an answer.
So sometimes you have to
spend a little bit more
than nothing for the
balsamic vinegar.
AUDIENCE: And I do I
keep it in the fridge,
or just like the oil?
NATHAN LYON: Just don't heat it.
You don't want to heat it up.
We have vinegars and olive
oils, and our stove is here,
but it's sort of
off to the side,
because sometimes the
heat can radiate and cook
things, mostly things that are
a bit more delicate like that.
So I have nine minutes
and 43 seconds.
We're going to bang out
this second recipe, right?
It involves heat, and
one of these cool things
that I heard, all of us
get one of these stove
tops at home, which
is really exciting.
I'm going to press this,
and I'm going to press this.
I think I'm doing this right.
Hey, Chef?
And then you see this-- if you
take the square root of that--
JENNA TAYLOR: I have one person
who touches these stoves.
NATHAN LYON: --and I multiply
that by-- that's right.
This one.
Geez, these are so cool.
I don't know if you guys
rent one bedrooms here,
but this is awesome.
Like this kitchen
is pretty awesome.
You've seen my kitchen.
You know what it looks like.
OK.
So Chef, can we got some samples
of the watermelon gazpacho?
Could you bring those out?
Those are coming out now.
Second thing.
This is fall coming in.
So cauliflower is
one of those things
that it's not a
super wow them thing.
You can roast them.
You need a high heat
for cauliflower,
because it's like 92% water.
So you need a lot of high
heat to bring some flavor out.
So I'm putting this on seven,
which isn't incinerate,
but it's pretty darn hot.
And we're just going
to let that heat up.
Does anybody have one of
these food processors?
Ah.
We need to get a Google
food processor for you
so you can just have them.
Food processors--
actually, you know what?
The immersion wand, or immersion
blender, which is like $38,
it comes with a mini
version of one of these.
So it'll take you three times.
Just cut it in thirds and
you can totally do that.
But they really come in handy.
Really, really do.
Just going to peel
these guys off.
They come in lots
of different colors,
so you can make this in green,
purple, all the different
colors here.
What I'm going to
do is I'm going
to cut this out,
cut out the stem,
save it, because it's
really delicious.
You just peel it with
your vegetable peeler,
with your ambidextrous vegetable
peelers that you have at home.
And what I want to do
is just break it off
into sort of like
regular bite-size pieces.
And put it in the
food processor.
Or you can just work
on your knife skills,
and just chop it like
it owes you money.
Just chop it.
You can do that, too.
Or you just borrow
his food processor.
So that goes on.
And we're going to pulse it.
So it's like the size
of a grain of rice.
There we go.
So I know some of
these, we're going
to have to pull out
and have a snack.
I just don't want
to go, but I can't
risk having it go liquid on me.
So-- these are just so crazy.
How do you get this one off?
JENNA TAYLOR: Left.
NATHAN LYON: Easy.
Thank you very much.
So the pan should be hot enough
to where it at least bubbles
and or barely starts to smoke.
The reason for that is,
if the pan's too cool
and you were to add the
olive oil and then this,
it would just steam.
And then it would just be mushy.
And then you could be
like, oh, actually,
instead of having this
cauliflower couscous,
we're going to have cauliflower
with cauliflower puree, which
wouldn't be such a bad thing.
So I have that go in.
And we're already
getting a few bubbles,
which is really nice,
which we're going to see.
Get that bad boy going.
Put that in here.
Any questions about
your samples, guys?
You guys are so funny.
Can't wait to exchange
Google numbers with you guys
or whatever I have to
do to be in the fold.
Do you get free TCHO
Chocolate over there?
So cool.
My goodness, it's just the best.
Man.
And I met up with the
chefs earlier for lunch.
You guys have some
really talented chefs.
I mean, if you see a chef,
or someone even playing
a chef on campus, I guess
you would call it, just say,
hey, great job.
It is literally the hardest
job I have ever had,
is being a chef in a restaurant.
So cauliflower goes
in, salt. So I'm
going to season it
with salt from up here.
I'm not going to just
go, bew, right there.
So when you season
it, you can see
it's sort of falling like
it-- actually, it's the wind,
so it's sort of falling on me.
But you can as
it's falling, it's
falling evenly, like a pyramid.
So if you were to
just hit that, whoever
gets that bite might
be a little bit,
like, just cut back on the
salt just a smidge, OK?
So all I want to do is--
either it's about to explode
and we all should just run
for it-- while that's cooking,
and I think it's still--
yeah, it's still on.
It's on eight.
While it's cooking, we're
going to add a few more things.
Not to that, but to this bowl.
Shallot.
You guys cook with
shallots at all?
Shallots are-- I want to make
sure you can see-- shallots
one of those things
you can actually
eat raw, which is why
chefs use shallots.
You can use them
in vinaigrettes.
You wouldn't necessarily eat the
red onion raw, but the shallot
you totally could.
So we're going to
make a vinaigrette.
And when this comes out, we're
going to-- thank you very much.
We're going to just
make the vinaigrette,
everything goes in here,
put that on top, stir it,
and we're going to
serve it, right?
Three minutes and 23
seconds of fame, here we go.
So I fully expect that we have
this email chain later on today
that I see that everyone
has a chef's knife
that they really
like working with.
AUDIENCE: I've got a question.
NATHAN LYON: Yes, sir.
AUDIENCE: So determining
the sharpness of the knife
and what you can
actually [INAUDIBLE].
NATHAN LYON: Yes.
AUDIENCE: So how do you do
it and what are [INAUDIBLE]?
JENNA TAYLOR: So
the question is,
how do you determine the
appropriate sharpness
for your knife?
How do you keep it
at that sharpness?
I wonder about that myself.
NATHAN LYON: You know, when
I went to culinary school,
I got really nerdville
on knives, like,
just getting them so sharp that
if I look at them I get cut.
Like really sharp.
Now, quite honestly, you
have these sharpeners
that you can get over the
counter at Bed Bath and Beyond
or whatever.
It's called Chefs-- Sarah, what
is that, the sharpener we have,
babe?
Chefs-- what is it?
It's like a little sharpener
that-- pull it off to the side.
that you can push and pull
through.
Those things, quite
honestly, are totally fine.
If you want to geek
over it, farmers markets
will have people
that sharpen it.
Or your local butcher
will have a sharpener
that you can
sharpen your knives.
The only thing that you
really need, quite honestly,
is a honing steel.
What you don't need is you don't
need the 21-block knife set.
I have so many knives.
I use this knife
95% of the time.
So I really only
need a sharp knife.
So if I say, what's
your favorite knife?
You're like, oh, the
one that's sharp,
the one that actually cuts.
That's my favorite one.
So a honing steel will take a
sharp knife and keep it sharp.
If you have a dull knife,
it needs to be sharpened.
A honing steel will do
nothing for a dull knife.
So every once in
a while, after I'm
done cooking for like 15
minutes, and I'll just hone it,
which straightens the
blade a little bit
and aligns the blade.
And then I just keep going.
And to answer your question, I
want them as sharp as possible.
I want them crazy sharp, because
that makes my job as a chef
easier.
I don't have to work
through the product.
I want to make friends
with the product.
So what I'm adding here is
a lot of cilantro-- sorry,
Victoria-- a lot of
cilantro, and also a lot
of parsley, flat
leaf Italian parsley.
AUDIENCE: One more
question over there.
NATHAN LYON: Yes.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Similar
to the question
about knives, [INAUDIBLE].
Talk to us about
your favorite pan.
NATHAN LYON: My favorite pan?
Oh, yeah, sure.
My favorite pan,
another great question.
Pots and pans are
one of those things
that are also very personal.
I find that if the pot or pan
is too heavy-- like All-Clad
is sort of the
industry standard,
but it has a straight handle,
so it puts a lot of stress
on your styloid process.
So it's actually a little
bit uncomfortable for me.
Let's see.
What are the ones-- we have
a lot-- what are the ones
that we use?
Yeah, Calphalon.
Calphalon Contemporary Series
stainless steel is great.
It's just inexpensive,
and it works really well,
and it has a handle.
It's curved, which I like.
And it's stainless
steel, which means
it's going to get a good sear
on the fish or the steak.
And you can make fond out
of it rather than nonstick.
It's a great question, though.
I mean, that's one of those,
like an eight-set piece.
I have four burners.
Why do I need a 12-
or 15-piece set?
Like I can only literally
cook four at a time.
Parmesan.
Parmigiano reggiano, which
we talked about before.
When you get a block of
Parmesan, that's better.
And then rewrap it really well.
It'll live indefinitely
in your fridge, OK?
So this is already caramelized.
It's a little bit
brown, which is nice.
A lot of water vapor
has gone away from it.
Get a little bit
of flavor in there.
Kosher salt, seasoning
from up high,
as we talked about earlier,
a little bit in my pocket.
There we go.
That's good.
Freshly ground black pepper.
Lemon juice and olive oil.
I already did, I think,
a half a lemon juice.
Let's get it going in here.
Catch the seeds.
They go here, and
then olive oil.
And I'm doing it around the side
so it doesn't soak up directly
into it.
And then what I'm going to do is
I'm just going to fold it, just
fold it together.
And then up here on
my left-hand side,
I do have the pine nuts
that we had toasted earlier.
And then how I toast my pine
nuts, and all nuts, in fact,
is in your cookbook that you
have in front of you right now.
Pine nuts.
They come from pine trees,
from freaking pine cones.
They are expensive, and
that's why they are expensive.
So let's not burn them.
And when they're good,
they're just like so good.
So I'm going to get some of
these and pop those on top.
Other than one
allergy to pine nuts,
does anyone not like pine nuts?
Great.
They're all going in there.
That's fantastic.
And then what we'll
do is we'll taste it.
So we have an acid,
which is the lemon juice.
We also have salt, which
is in the form of salt.
And then we also have the
cheese, which has salt in it
also.
So it's a little bit different
because it's buttery.
So we'll give it a flavor,
a little flavor test here.
And then we'll see what happens.
It's like I made it before.
This is really-- it's
great, because it
has a lot of fresh herbs in it.
Never be afraid of herbs.
People are like, what do
you do with all those herbs?
You use them.
I mean, you just use them.
And the more herbs, the better.
It's like when you
have Thai food,
they just throw so
many herbs on there.
There's never been
a moment I was
like, that's a lot of herbs.
Can you just cut
back on the herbs?
I've always been very happy with
the volume of herbs in my food.
And again, you eat
with your eyes.
Make it really pretty.
I'm not a-- I'm not
one of those dudes that
has the tweezer things.
There's nowhere in my
cookbook this says, go out
and get a thing of surgical
tweezers to compose your food.
I'm not saying you
can't, because I've
seen some beautifully
composed dishes.
But because I feel that
we're all family now,
this is all family style.
And we can all pass
this around here
at Team Google-- I'm just
coming up with these things
left and right.
And I used all the cheese.
But if you had a little
fresh cheese, the block,
you would just shave
some over the top,
because that's really sexy, and
it's just beautiful big pieces
of Parmesan.
And that's the second dish.
Super fast, all within zero
seconds, which I'm sure
has been there for at
least a little while.
Could be, could be.
That's it, guys.
I'm sure you would tell me if
I had stuff in my teeth, which
I'm sure I do.
But thanks for your time.
Any questions, I'm
ready to take them
[APPLAUSE]
JENNA TAYLOR: I have a
question about cauliflower.
NATHAN LYON: Question.
JENNA TAYLOR: It's one of
my favorite vegetables.
I love it.
But I notice that
sometimes I buy a head,
and it sits in my fridge, and
it has a terrible strong smell.
And sometimes it's
completely neutral.
It doesn't smell like anything,
completely unoffensive.
What causes that?
How do I differentiate?
Does it matter?
NATHAN LYON: I mean, it's
breaking down, for one.
It's the same-- I believe
it's the same family as kale.
Like kale will give
you that same smell.
If it's constricted
at all-- you want
to make sure the airflow
happens around it.
I'm using the
analogy of the kale.
When you get kale home and
it has that little twisty tie
and or fresh herbs, you need to
get it out of that twisty tie.
It doesn't like
to be constrained,
because when they're
smooshed together like that,
the leaves or the
herbs, what happens
is any of that moisture
will actually begin to rot.
And that's when it breaks down.
Think of spinach.
When you get a bag
of spinach, and it's
been sitting in your fridge
or in your crisper drawer
that you call like
the death drawer
or whatever you call,
because right now
there's a bunch of flaccid
vegetables in your death
drawer.
I know it for a fact.
We could go take a
Google van, I know it.
It's just because, when you
look at the bottom of the bag,
you're like, ooh, that's
weird dark spinach juice.
That's disgusting.
It's because it can't breathe.
So if I ever get fresh-- if
I'm traveling doing something,
and I want a salad, I'll
get the package of salad,
and I'll poke a bunch of holes
in it and put it in the fridge.
The holes will
allow it to exhale,
but it won't dehydrate
hydrate because it's not
completely exposed.
So that's why the
crisper drawer is there,
so it won't dehydrate
it like it would if it's
on top of just a drawer.
So it stays cool enough.
But you need to let
it breathe, also.
But that's a great question.
Great question.
OK.
The question is, what are my
favorite spices to cook with?
I think that sort of
depends on the cuisine.
It's interesting.
So when you look at spices and
you're thinking, all right,
well, here's a chili and cumin
and fennel, or definitely
cumin.
One of our friends who's on
Food Network, Aarti Sequeira,
she's like, oh, that's
my people's food.
That's Indian food.
And actually, the
dude from El Salvador
is like, actually,
that's our people's food.
So depending upon
what date the spice
trades came through your
country, I guess that depends.
I really love cumin.
I just love cumin.
I love fresh fennel.
But I also like
growing things at home.
So we have a curry tree at home.
It's like four years old,
but it's only this tall.
It's unbelievably slow grower.
But with those three things,
you can just make so much food.
But black pepper is one of those
things that I have to have.
And we bang through--
our black pepper grinder
is about this big, and we rip
through this olive oil, and one
this big, every month.
Like we just kill it.
We just rip through it.
If you're not just
destroying your olive oil,
put it on your cereal.
I don't care what you do.
But it's just so good for
you, and it tastes so good.
Great question, though.
Thank you.
Any more questions, guys?
Yes, sir.
AUDIENCE: Besides olive oil,
other cooking oils and choosing
one versus another?
NATHAN LYON: So the question
is, other than olive oil,
what are other oils
that I would use?
So I mainly use olive oil.
And I use grape seed oil.
So one is for most utilitarian
things, like the olive oil.
But higher temperatures, I
would use grape seed oil,
also keeping in mind that Sarah,
my girlfriend and executive
sous chef, we do a lot of
drought-friendly recipes.
And grapes, wine grapes don't
take a lot of water to grow,
and the seeds are already there.
So you just press them.
So you have this double whammy.
It's a neutral oil and it
has a very high smoke point,
and it's heart healthy.
So those two.
So if I'm making a
vinaigrette or a mayonnaise
that I want to
flavor and I don't
want it to taste like olive
oil, I would definitely
use grape seed oil.
And it's just a lovely
oil to work with.
Great question.
Thank you.
Any more questions?
Yes, ma'am.
AUDIENCE: Do you have
any common go to recipes
when you're at home and just
want to make something quick?
NATHAN LYON: Because I worked
at farmers markets for 10 years,
it depends what we
brought back in the truck.
We always have lemons.
Like right now, we have
a lot of stone fruit.
The thing is, I've gotten
to the point where I just
love fresh produce so much.
I just love it so much that
I let it sort of guide me.
So the other day we
had so many peaches,
these lovely yellow
peaches, O'Henry peaches.
But we had lemons, too.
And I was like, oh,
well, let's just
take those O'Henry peaches.
We'll peel them.
We'll throw in a little
bit of diced fresh mint
and I'll make a simple
syrup with organic sugar.
And then I'll have lemon
zest with the lemon juice.
And that right there
that's peach sorbet.
And all I had to do
was put it in a blender
and throw it in the
processor, or in your freezer,
and just put it in the processor
after it's already frozen.
With the rest the peaches,
we'll make into a chutney,
like a peach spicy-- fresh
ginger peach chutney.
So and I learned a
lot of these things
from chefs that
I've worked under.
But I've also learned
a lot just from being
at farmers markets,
because chances are,
your local chefs are
standing right next to you
getting stuff from
them, and just listening
what people do with that.
Because I'll do that all the
time, and I sell the stuff.
But I go, oh, what would you
do-- how do you pick that out?
And they go, oh, I do this and
this is what I do with that.
And then I step on it and run it
over the car, whatever they do.
Which is very interesting.
And you learn a lot from that.
But right now, because
it's summer time,
and it is hot in our
house, hot, so we
don't really want
to turn on the oven.
So heirloom tomatoes, burrata
cheese, lots of fresh herbs.
I'll turn on the grill
outside and grill up
crostini with olive oil
and salt and pepper,
and we'll just monch
it, just go crazy.
Yeah.
But whatever we do,
there's just the two of us.
And we eat.
We eat.
Capital eat.
We just Google it down.
We kill it.
Good question.
But thank you.
I mean, whatever's in
the season of summer,
really, we'll just destroy it.
Any more questions?
You had another question?
AUDIENCE: So how does that go?
JENNA TAYLOR: So what's your
process for creating recipes?
Do you each your mistakes?
How do you filter them out?
NATHAN LYON: Everyone
eats their mistakes.
Never make this mistake again.
JENNA TAYLOR: Those
tears, one at a time.
NATHAN LYON: My
girlfriend's very strong.
Eat, eat that mistake.
It's not quite that bad.
But the process is,
because I teach on TV,
it has to be accessible
to the home cook
regardless where
you get your food,
be it in the farmers
market in Palo Alto,
or at-- the majority
of Americans
get their stuff from Wal Mart.
And then we'll sometimes also
go to different grocery stores
to get a particular
product, and then
design the recipe making
sure that it works with all
of those different products from
all those different sources,
because it's just simply not
fair being in California,
being like, you
know, in December,
when we eat Driscoll
strawberries
from the organic garden
and the virgin cherubs come
and they pick them for us--
like that's just not fair
when you're freezing your
changs off in Maine, right?
So-- what's the question?
I just got a little
bit distracted.
JENNA TAYLOR: How do
you create recipes?
NATHAN LYON: So creating--
thank you so much.
Glad people are
paying attention.
Creating recipes
is sort of like,
what do we have a lot
of in the kitchen?
What do we not
necessarily-- what direction
have we not gone into?
That's why when we eat
out, we'll eat out food
that we're not
necessarily familiar with,
but you want to educate
America and make
it accessible for them.
So my dad hated eggplant.
He hated eggplant,
or brussels sprouts.
My mom would just
cook it until it was
like mushy brussels sprout ass.
It was horrible, and your
kitchen smelled horrible.
But then I came to
California, and I
was like, oh, roasted
brussels sprouts
with balsamic and shallots.
So delicious.
It' crispy, it's sweet.
It is a vastly different animal.
So we also try to think
out of the box and say,
most people eat it this way.
How do we prepare
it a different way?
So they're not just bored
with the same old routine of,
these are my five
dishes I always turn to.
My family likes two
of them, but I'm
going to make them
because I'm tired.
So how can we reinvent
the cauliflower
to where you don't just
have to either make
a puree out of it--
which is delicious--
throw it in a food processor,
steam it with butter, salt
and pepper, done.
Or you can cut into slabs and
throw it in your broiler at 450
with a lot of spices, and make
these big slabs, or steaks.
Done.
So we're trying to say, how do
you utilize the same ingredient
in a new and exciting way
that perhaps hasn't been done
before, or sort of
splinter off in a way
that all Americans will be
like, I can totally do that.
I have-- except for the young
lady on my left-- I totally
have this.
So that's why I
designed the gazpacho.
Instead of making
people be like,
oh, you're going to do
this brunoisette of this,
and people aren't
going to do that.
But they can go
bzzz, dinner's ready.
So I hope that
answered your question.
It's sort of like, what
do we cook for ourselves?
What do we cook for
drought-friendly recipes
for this demographic?
The show that I got
the Emmy nomination for
is a slightly
different demographic
than Food Network or PBS.
So we have to kind of figure
out what goes in what slot.
But that's a fantastic question.
JENNA TAYLOR: Sounds like
just playing in your kitchen
with whatever's current,
fresh, vibrant produce.
NATHAN LYON: With
the rest of that,
the rest of the
watermelon, we would just
go hog wild on that bad boy.
JENNA TAYLOR: Google
it right down.
NATHAN LYON: I'm going
to Google it down.
Put it up on my Google
wall of whatever you--
I don't know what you guys do.
JENNA TAYLOR: Googly.
Googly is the word you
can start applying now.
NATHAN LYON: Googly?
JENNA TAYLOR: Googly.
It's a thing.
NATHAN LYON: Feel
like being tickled.
So Googly.
JENNA TAYLOR: Well,
thank you so much.
Anything else?
NATHAN LYON: I don't know.
JENNA TAYLOR: Thank you so much.
NATHAN LYON: Thanks, guys.
Thank you.